Want to know what's heating up in theaters this weekend?
- What happened here?
A crew exploring a distant planet makes an unimaginable and terrifying discovery in Alien Covenant.
- Holy ...
- The great athlete road trip.
*he screams*
"Diary of a Wimpy Kid: The Long Haul"
sends the Heffley family hilariously off-course.
- This is my whole world. I'm 18 and I've never been outside.
A teen with a rare disease falls for the boy next door in "Everything, everything".
- I'm willing to sacrifice everything to live one perfect day
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So, what's your weekend ticket going to be?
Let us know by commenting.
See you next time on weekend ticket.